I love my husband. I love him even though
he's snoring. Wakes me up every morning.
It's my daily bench
food network says you should
only get one item in your eggs,
but Louis likes everything in them
cause it's how his mom made them.
He calls it eggs with
everything I call it grows,
but that's how he loves them.
Especially when the boys
and I do all the laundry because my mom
told me that a man with dirty clothes as
a man that's not loved by his wife.
Yeah,
I know it's old fashioned now is whites
are always white and all his coworkers
will know he's loved.
He always promises to do it next time,
but I'll never let him.
Okay.
I know he loves me because every time I
hit off to work I feel him watching me
leave sl
uniform.
One of my favorite things
is my commute to work.
It's my time to myself and
it lets me clear my head
before the stress of the day.
Yeah.
It looks like you have c d or Fukes.
Coronial endothelial dystrophy
I can barely pronounce
is taking away my vision
and I will probably lose
my whole career over it.
I won't be able to scare the we anymore.
What am I supposed to tell him?
Okay.
I can't make it silly.
Anx with everything.
Have a bad dream or did you
all right?
Sorry.
The people he works with are going
to think I stopped caring about him.
Just talk to me.
Right,
so thing is going on. Something is
wrong. You're not talking to me.
Please tell me what's going on.
Now when all I want to do is
breathe and walk to work alone,
I can't because they won't let me.
How do you tell the person you
love that you're going blind?
I can't help but think that I'm
becoming is patient, not his partner.
Maybe he'd be happy with someone else.
Someone who won't be a burden.
My wife is going blind you.
She doesn't want my help.
I want to wake up every morning
and tell her that I love her.
That's all going to be okay
of.
I wish I could do all the cooking,
but she says, don't do it.
She's even figured out the laundry.
Start going to work.
Taking the bus alone
stops every time to think about it.
Crossing streets of downtown,
even though she doesn't know
every day,
because that's what you're love is right.
This is more than just a feeling.
It's an action
Sicilian.
We'll never know which I do for him.
That's how I still love her.